what is your sense about our
our time and the future hope about the
decentralization
of power do you think that's something
that we can actually achieve
uh given that power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
it's so wonderful to be
absolutely powerful well good question
so first of all i believe that by the
way there is a
it's a complex questions uh lex um um
uh and like uh all the rest of your
questions
i'm so very sorry it's okay i am
enjoying it
so but um so there are two things first
of all
power has been um centralized for a
variety of reasons
when you want to get it is easier for
somebody uh
even a single person to grab power but
there is also
some kind of a technology lack thereof
that justified having power because
in a way in a society in which even
communication never mind blockchain
which is
common knowledge but even simple
unilateral communication
is hard it is much easier to say
you do as i say because the alternative
but as so there is a little bit of a
technology barrier
but i think of it and and now to get to
this common knowledge
it is a totally different story now we
have finally the technology for doing
this so
that is one part but i really believe
that you know not
by having a distributed system not only
you don't have a
you have actually much more stable and
durable system
because not only for corruption but even
for things that go astray and give it a
long enough time
by stranger version of murphy's law
whatever goes wrong goes wrong
and so and if the power is diffused
you actually are much more stable if you
look at uh
any any living uh
complex living being is distributed i
mean
i'm uh i don't know if somebody is a
okay tell silvia now it's time to eat
right so you have millions of cells in
your body you have billions of bacteria
exactly help me in the guts everything
you know we are in a soup of it somehow
it keeps us alive it is uh and
so and strange enough however when we
design systems
we designed them centralized we
ourselves are distributed beings and
when we plan to say okay i want to
create an architecture
how about i make a pyramid i put
west on the top and the power flows down
and um
and so again it's a little bit perhaps
of a
technology problem but now the
technology is there so that is a big
challenge
to rethink how we want to organize power
um
in very large system and uh
and and distribute the system in my
opinion are much more resilient
let's put them this way there was a mine
of my
italian competitors right you know
machiavelli who
who looked at the time there was a big
there was a bunch of a small state a
democratic republic of florence of
venison and the other thing
and there was the ottoman empire but at
the time was an empire
and uh assad and was very centralized
and he made a political observation
that goes roughly to say whenever you
have such a centralized thing it's very
hard
to overtake but that former government
is centralized
but if you get it it's so easy to keep
the population one instead of
with other things are much more
resilient when the power is distributed
is much more it's going to be lasting
for a much longer time
and ultimately maybe the human spirit
wants that kind of resilience wants that
kind of distribution
it's just that we didn't have technology
throughout history machiavelli didn't
have
the computer the internet and uh
is certainly part of a reason yes
you